you know what i'm saying brennan yeah
right now hey we got cupcakes in front
of us we got cupcakes and whiskey it
says happy birthday killer well we got
one other person in this room without a
birthday happy birthday killer
oh
you know on the weekends it's always
pretty camping
large bodies of water large bodies of
water
what chin does on the weekends yeah we
got something we're talking about your
birthday's on sunday right yeah yeah
yeah the 17. can you turn how old
45 dude holy
oh i'm not 45 yet so yeah you're 45 you
know
but hey let him get it on
anything for your b day my girl actually
planned a a trip to the great lakes and
she got us a sprinter camper van yeah so
we're just doing like a a quick
three-day trip on sunday chicago-ish
area holy [ __ ] there was a blizzard or a
michigan yeah
that's all scared of there was a
blizzard apparently it's dying down
you're going to drive from here no no
i'm flying oh
she got tickets to fly there and then
she rented a sprinter done for three
days right and then we're doing we're
wearing campgrounds you fly places so
when you kidnap people
yeah
it's easier is that how you get your
bodies
but why is it why are you up there chin
she just wanted to plant something cool
because it it's good fishing and camping
oh that's what i love to do
yeah and you've never been up that way
never the great lakes it's pretty cool
but it's going to be super cold and
windy so i don't know if it sounds like
fish
we have a van i have an actual sprinter
van
that's decked out yeah you got a
sprinter
i get it look it'll be nice and cozy
that's the van she goes
oh that'll be fun chen people are
tricking those vans out yeah they cost a
lot of money
yeah oh it costs a lot it's like the new
tour bus
they're mercedes sprinters so and uh
you're gonna be spending your entire day
in that van oh yeah yeah four four-day
trip i love that stuff you make do you
make you don't take dookies in there
right no you shouldn't there's a
bathroom in there there's a toilet but
you should there's a toilet the sprinter
everything yeah yeah
yeah that's why you shouldn't do that
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] shoe damn look how
nice it looks
[Music]
no this oh
the baller comics are using those for
us now yeah
it's really cool lights oh
i could live in that sink
sort of
do it you think you wouldn't do it yeah
it could get you thinking and that
mighty crap listen i'm a simple kind of
man yeah i don't need much yep go ahead
and do it people think that just because
you guys wouldn't do it people think
they can oh there it is i could i know i
could until you're in a van is that your
shower yeah toilet shower toilet
[Laughter]
yeah yeah 45 that's crazy the shot no
dude it's a trip make sure you don't get
that toilet paper wet but you will you
know what i'm saying yeah no they
probably have no it's protected that's
plastic on it yeah
also you you rent it like it's like an
airbnb site it's like just like that
yeah it's easy like that it costs more
dudes 300 something a night
that's actually not bad similar price to
something yeah but i mean think about a
hotel it could be a cheap airbnb oh okay
yeah that'd be
a rough airbnb yeah you can get some
pretty good airbnb's where you're going
for that
no but i don't know i want to do this
though on the outskirts of chicago
yeah you're doing it yeah outskirts for
sure
yeah lake erie that's where we're going
lake here like oh you'd find some you
could find some
you could find a house but this is what
i want to do though that's what he likes
yeah
no i understand
it's all good now could we not go to
bear big bear on our own
you've already done we've done all the
places right so your dream is so this is
your dream she planned this i didn't
think about it different fish i love you
yeah walleye
look at your girls just as into camping
as you i know i'm lucky i'm super lucky
yeah no i don't think she's she balls
deep in camping was she doing it before
she loves it she loves because you love
it yeah
no not that much oh so you got her into
it you guys bond we bought especially
over stuff like this and it's just gonna
be youtube just us too
so it's gonna be a little bit
challenging
hey we better not hear that same story
about you dawg when you're in your tent
um or wherever and then and the forest
cannibals come for you
forest cannibals yeah you mean chin
strapped no just the people that you
know they're those hill people that
sometimes in west virginia yeah it's
only they're not in chicago that's what
you never know
you never know they want to i'll be
ready
you're by far the youngest right i know
chris christian how old are you
christian i'm 20
i'm 23.
and you're
you're still under 30 right cat yeah i'm
26. you're still young super young yeah
you started here young yeah i i think
it's my four year working here like in
august
2018 yeah that's all oh wow [ __ ] it was
like 22 23. that's awesome that's
amazing been here for a hot minute
hotmail shin's been here for a hot
second too 45 now 45. i met you at 39.
so that was pretty old as it is
that's when i walked up to you as uh
actually
i know you can't tell dave you really
can't tell that's awesome i thought you
were i thought you were 42. i didn't
know you were hitting 45. yeah like 42.
no i i knew he was in his 40s but i
thought he was 42 i didn't know but
that's like the that's the line right
now 45
that's kind of a trippy place oh yeah
five years away from five i know that's
crazy try 55 i know right but you look
great i can't believe it like i i swear
to god when you meet other people who
are 55 you're like first of all future's
here second of all
you're like you feel like you start
living you feel like you just got like
you don't know how you got here yeah you
both look at each other like
you're like i know
oh okay yeah like how the [ __ ] did this
happen when i say 45 comparison to most
55 year olds like you're you're fine
well probably but it's still it's 55
figures an effort yeah what's that
saying the red queen problem they call
they call it in alice in wonderland in
my kingdom you have to run as fast as
you can just to stay in the same place
like as as you're when you're older
you don't understand that analogy that
doesn't make sense no you're gonna have
to break that one down for me think
about it what think about it again say
it again in my kingdom you have to run
as fast as you can just to stay in the
same place
so
you know you're always when you get to a
certain point and an age
every day you're getting closer to death
you're getting uglier and weaker in a
way right like your body's breaking down
about who you are yeah so you you but
there's a point where you have to just
like it's not like i'm going to work out
like a [ __ ] and next year i'm
going to be in better shape
i'll stay in the same place
oh got it like this is it this is it
this is you gotta run as fast as you can
time is your enemy you're not gonna get
any better yeah any worse everybody's
exciting time though everybody everybody
finds it but you still at 40 you can
still you know you're okay at 45
technically your times would be better
in a tough mudder if you really push
yourself no because you're losing that
good yeah yeah he ain't got no good no
more but never really as you get older
this is something crazy what happens
though a little bit what wisdom
yeah letting go
there's a lot of positives too letting
go of [ __ ] you've been holding on to i
think it's weird when people are like
don't want to get old and like get like
they're like upset about it i'm like say
your age who cares well that's that's i
don't know who's upset i mean well watch
out there's people that get people that
fight it like with fighting botox like
watching madonna try to stay young in a
very clumsy way is disconcerting it's
crazy well it's it's a mess it's it's
she's a mess her ass her face it's it's
it's just go to her instagram just look
at me because i yeah no no she's 65 now
she's up there she's holding that is she
71 no she's not 71. take a look
i mean not far from 95 though she's not
like she's a young lady 63 63 okay go to
the ground now you're 63. now look at
look at this
it's the strangest
strangest [ __ ]
okay
it's tough to tell on uh
oh she does look pretty well that's
probably a filter there cat yeah it's
definitely a filter what is she doing
here
she's blowing kisses
her nostrils are she
she has a filter on a big filter it must
be really tough though when you're you
know when you're at that high
and that's her son she adopted yeah yeah
it must be really tough though when
you're you know you're the freaking on
top of the world with your looks and
music yeah nothing like you just don't
want to give it up but that that we
could look at yeah hey bubba that went
about way 20 years ago like you've got
to let it go you've got to kind of
figure out a way to yeah you've got to
figure out a way to transition into
something else
you feel like she's trying to do like
the same thing it's this way she's just
like fighting
look at that
like yeah like come on
you know i get that you're doing
everything you can but you're not that
age dude you don't you don't think but
63 she looks pretty well and of course
but that this
it's weird [ __ ] she's still chin go back
but these are these is that an ad for
the hellcat dodge or did she steal the
logo where is this where the one you
just clicked on oh was she sitting down
in the chair yeah next good good thing
do you want to race me
let's do this
go again this one oh that is a picture
of a uh that's the hellcat yeah it's
really cool that's a great logo oh dude
oh that car is a banshee
but it's kind of yeah it's hard to tell
because these are all filters
i'm just saying that this is a strange
way to try to stay relevant that's all
yeah the ones that age gracefully yeah
especially older guys or women you know
yeah elizabeth hurley yeah you could but
like guys when they start like pierce
brosnan pierce bronson but madonna can
almost be like in a position of wisdom
and older where she could
she could kind of like
you know part of being older at that age
is to be a teacher to be to be an
example of
i don't know grace but also maybe she
could be happy she could she could be
doing that i don't think but just i
think she's such a radical narcissist
that it's still about her and such a
narcissist that she can't see how insane
this is you don't think she's probably
happy with what she's doing i don't
think there's anything called happiness
there i think there's only there's only
this strange ambition this this it's
like
that you don't have to look like a tick
tocker the racism right the race is over
and you're sitting there on your ferrari
and you finished first place yeah yeah
yeah
definitely definitely first place you
keep coming back to this goddamn race
yes and and also being mean to people
like lady gaga critical of them and
caddy and it's like it's very strange
well it's because lady gaga it's her
time right sure
oh so yeah she's probably her ego's like
who the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] yeah you know
it's fine i but but it's just it's just
uh you see i think anybody who does that
that's it we know that's a losing battle
right we need to use that you can rage
against the knight they call it raging
against tonight okay fine you don't have
to raging against the wrinkles you rage
yeah yeah aging against the ring raging
gets through now i don't mind a little
bit of work right i don't either no yeah
there's a little yeah yeah yeah you can
get that hair done get your hair you
tighten your face up a tad little bow
tie maybe a little botox i could get
fillers i'm not going to i'm just saying
if you did that like i get it right but
when you're doing it there's nothing
wrong with that you're doing like
everything and your filters and your
just and your your braids and your
dressing
it's just this strange
this strange sort of like
rage yeah it's like this no it's like
you know vampires when they die they
take everybody with them yeah they're
like ah you know it's almost like that's
how it feels man let's take a break dude
let's take a break take a break
we've been talking about milking each
other you can get a break from sometimes
i get a break from that look you need a
break in general and you need a break in
life and i'll tell you something i need
you know what i need is a good mattress
because i need a break to get some rest
your biggest break is at night when you
take your rest you got to get seven
eight hours of sleep
eight hours but i do too you run it hard
i run it hard on bamboo you got anything
else like helix sleep mask dude i keep
telling you you can't take that that
stray bamboo you found in the back yard
heap i know you can't do that and you
can't sleep on hay i need to talk to you
about helix sleep it's a helix mattress
they are they they you basically take a
quiz yeah two minute quiz dude everybody
has a different kind of box
i did the quiz i'm waiting for my
mattress i took a two minute quiz i got
soft mattresses yeah dude however you
sleep firm mattresses dude we're not
talking about your run-of-the-mill
mattress built for every joe schmoe out
there it's built for my thick ass if you
sleep hot they got something that cools
you okay dude i love it and you know
what i don't have the helix mattresses
they're all my guest beds and i got my
mother-in-law father-in-law my dad my
mom everybody trying to stay with me i'm
like wow they must like my company nope
nope they're just like my helix sleeping
mattress i sleep in one you and you're a
plus size sleeper i'm a plus size model
i'm a plus size model you need a big old
they they need something and you
probably sleep on your tummy i don't
know i don't want to get personal i'll
see why by the way if you do fart if you
sleep on your side if you sleep on your
tummy if you sleep on your back i got
the mattress for you a customized
mattress so if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress that you're matched to the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to the mattress store again helix is
awesome but you don't need to take my
words yeah by the way we can we can tell
you all you want why don't you hey i
guess i guess gq in 2020 ever heard of
it yeah when helix was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 and wired magazine said the same
big time man just go to helixsleep.com
fighter take their two-minute sleep quiz
they'll match you with the perfect
mattress just for your big booty give me
a 10-year warranty and let them sleep on
it for a hundred nights risk-free guys
i'll even pick it up if you don't love
it but you will so don't worry about it
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows
they got financing options yes for all
the listeners and viewers of fighter and
kid
for 2 helixsleep.com
off all mattress orders 200
i want total human optimization on my
brain i need stuff for my brain i need
help i need stuff to sleep better i need
stuff to digest better i need daily
support dude we know daddy's on
carnivore diet so i gotta take the
digestive enzymes with every meal
because you have a breakdown you gotta
break down that red meat talking about
it dude o-n-n-i-t on it yup you're on it
all the time i'm on it dad you always
got some alpha brain going you always
got some i live off alpha brain krill
oil yep krill oil the the immune support
for your collection i needed because
your boy's been sick a lot this last
year definitely where your masking
happened out there i've had every
variant um yeah the keto collection they
got the summer collection gut health
which we swear by here nutrition we got
coffee for your ass we got whey protein
protein bars mct oil elk bars warrior
bars we got it all man and fitness gear
we got streaming fitness home demand
fitness programs club mesas steel mace's
quad maces primo bells kettlebells
sandbags battle ropes
what else you want man everything to get
your stick ass in shape this year come
run a tough mudder and get your thick
ass in shape with on it on it.com slash
fighter 10 off on it dot com slash
fighter 10 percent off wait dolly part i
don't know uh dolly parton is all natty
yeah
new she's not dolly parton is an expert
but she seems like she but she seems
like but she's
she seems like she's pretty cool and
like she's so cool she's a leader yeah
she's awesome
always looked down on us being like this
country girl and she always kept her
yeah but she's a [ __ ] soft writer
she's like a dolly [ __ ] she's she's a
she's got a lot of work incredible
songwriters yeah now she's a lot of work
but she wrote i will always love you
she's written so many songs it's crazy
jolene she she's a hello
she's she's just another lover
so cute so talented awesome tits for
days god dawg get your titties out for
four digits
on playboy back in the day yeah did
today's did today's always classy though
always no she's very very classy and you
see these guys would call her a country
bumpkin and things and the way she would
handle those interviews was astonishing
well she's a monster she's a mom in a
great way yeah and she's been with the
same dude for ever yeah
yeah and that's there's just something
different about that you know there's
dolly world she has like her own disney
world
yeah it's like i think tennessee or
somewhere oh [ __ ] i think she's been
married to the same man for yeah you
know 50 years or whatever it is that's
him right but well he's not fighting
isn't it interesting that dolly parton
somehow we don't have the same criticism
dolly parton somehow seems in many ways
to be
um uh
i don't know she's still in the way she
delivers herself we still she's classy
yes i'll say this the way she's
accepting that she's an older woman yeah
whereas madonna is
not doing that dollyworld hollywood
woodward dollywood if you see if you see
some of the other pictures on a [ __ ]
theme park dude
the thing about dolly she embraces like
even like the new culture like uh yeah
uh
what's her [ __ ] face miley cyrus to
cover jolene yeah that's her
granddaughter actually and miley that's
her goddaughter
oh [ __ ] she did good amazing
she killed it miley cyrus
her brother her brother used to be in a
band that's a troll station central
station no one's faking the pop scene
right
her sister uh or the punks i know she's
uh her brother one of them i thought her
sister dabbled in the punk world too no
it was her brother my brother did that
guy trace he's like all like look at him
oh jesus christ oh wow
he's alive jesus christ that's him yep
dude when your dad sings don't break my
heart might make you break your heart
you're going to be lost man
no he's doing good i think he's not lost
no he's cool looking wow those tats are
sick those are serious a lot of work now
on the left let's not do that though
yeah that's oh that's old look let's not
do it i think that's i think the one on
the right is him that's not that's him
now that's him now yeah that is not dude
wait go to miley cyrus adam22 what's her
name noah cyrus noah cyrus hold on i
don't know hold on i think she just does
yeah he's a lot to take in what is going
on with this guy where
what do you mean where
i mean what the [ __ ] is going on
you get it
huh
but what is that about your dad's that
big of a rock star it's a tough world of
navigation and your sister's a big
[ __ ] star as well
is that sort of like things i'm not what
they are but i'm gonna do that
they're all
i feel like they're all pretty
successful
right i don't know yeah in their own
right i would say and they're all right
yeah yeah i mean miley definitely the
biggest by the way yeah okay the other
ones are there no no hey noah's popping
is she noah's popping out not anywhere
near miley yeah
oh my god they look identical
no
no similar but
i love miley cyrus i think she's yeah i
like she's
sexiest my best friend lizzie says she's
just me and miley
uh yeah uh folks with miley cyrus noah
had a big uh hit too though in country
she did a collab with somebody who's a
big kid i remember but she's got a good
voice cat yeah she's a beautiful person
oh really yeah she writes really well
too oh damn she writes her [ __ ] too oh
yeah jimmy allen who's huge jimmy
allen's huge
he oh this okay oh b i got a new show
for you on netflix i know what it is
called the ultimatum i just watched it
last night i'm full i i went to bed at
midnight last night watching four
episodes have you seen the cat
i didn't get a chance oh my lord give me
more i'm telling you my girlfriend
better you might grab nothing to watch
i'm like there has to be something the
ultimatum so we go to netflix and it
pops up and i remember seeing the
trailer after you watched love is blind
that that was the new show they were
doing like i can't wait for that totally
forgot about it and i'm like it's
available
clicked on it bro
this [ __ ] it's all couples
and they and one of them right you find
these shots
i'm obsessive
but so it's all couple it's like
whatever six or eight couples yeah and
one of them whether it's the girl or the
guy give the other one an ultimatum okay
where we got to get married or break up
so they go up this show's nuts they go
on this [ __ ] show with these other
couples but they break up just for the
three weeks they have to live with
somebody else that they mix with for
three weeks like another like another oh
i don't decide whether you get married
or not it's so awkward too is it
it's kind of a spoiler in three go ahead
and do one for me
episode three
is
the best drama i've ever seen on youtube
tell me because i only saw bro
tell them
i'm not i won't tell what happens but
let me just give you the premises yeah
so they sit down at a table with nick
lachey and his girl yes and they all
have to make come to like all right who
do you choose yes but it's awkward
because right the guy's fiance's there
and he has to choose this other girl
let's tell why
it i bet the producers like what what
the [ __ ] dude it is
such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
because it's because i told my grandma
it's
grandmother
i told my girl i can't believe they're
even agreeing to us and then episode
three you realize that
that this wasn't a good idea and it
the entire show hits the [ __ ] [ __ ]
show it's
it's a disaster
some [ __ ] happens that they weren't
planning on
well because dude think about this you
and your girl you're not married no but
you're engaged yeah okay let's before
the kid let's she goes ultimatum we're
going on this show yeah you were you're
gonna be single for three weeks if you
find a connection with another girl and
you realize that you vibe with her
better than me
i i'm that's fine and while we're
talking about now it's all good but then
when you go into this wherever they're
at you go into this house or you go into
this this [ __ ] hotel and you see your
girl talking with a that's a giant
athletic black guy that's it who's
handsome
and you're like and you're talking about
jai and you're like
oh wait i didn't i didn't think it was
like yeah [ __ ] no no and they're all on
they're all on dates but they're around
each other yeah i i can't believe they
even signed up for it they're just
trying to test the strength of their
love i guess well it's ultimatums like
hey after this three weeks we either get
married or i need to move on somebody
else yeah
but the way they cast it there's one guy
on there with this girl and he just you
know they go around like they make the
rounds to see if they're a match yeah
and he matches this girl
and i was like there's no
they start talking
they're soul mates
and the guy realizes like oh my girl
sucks this girl is fantastic then they
start living together dude now hold on
is she on the show all right hold on
yeah she's a lot she's alive which one
is that her
her uh fiance is great he's this
light-skinned redheaded kid his mom's a
talent his dad's black he's really light
skinned she's a lot i know that one
she's alive oh she's hot though i like
her yeah dude in episode three she goes
off she says what everybody's thinking
and you're like okay yes queen okay so
so wait
so just because i gotta watch this i was
up until two in the morning watching the
first episode now oh damn here's my
question yeah she's great here's my
question great personality are you
saying i like her she might be my
favorite
but the other one has the
bobby
yes
one looks like adele and she was in a
thong she's exactly what she looks like
i told my girl i went oh
look at the bottom well my girl got mad
at me because my girl my girl was like
get off me and it was like this i'm like
i'm just saying [ __ ] thinks that
black guy so my girl goes would you ever
go on that show i said let me tell you
this right now if you came to me with an
ultimatum before we had kids got married
and you're like we're gonna go on the
show to see if this works it's too late
how about long faces
how about long face no no come on don't
don't say that hey hey no hold on no
no no
no she has a long face
that's like call me big dad
bring up those orange
candies the peanut
why is this me i don't this is these are
facts brian i don't want to talk about
that that's her face
and you know what you'll see episode
three what happens okay fine anyways let
me see this let me see this look-alike
nail buddy matches with she's nobody
matches
she's no she's an ad not a very nice
person no she's that's not nice no not
at all she goes she goes i can't marry a
guy who doesn't make more money than me
she goes i'll tell you right now if my
uh fiance doesn't come up with more
money it's not going to work really and
one guy's like you suck man and he's
like i'm just not attracted you move on
it's hilarious and she doesn't get it
where's this she's like okay i'm not
attractive yeah and you know what
there are people there are plenty of
guys that would find her very attractive
and like her she yeah nobody in this
room she created me
let me bring up um she's tatted up in
her body remember her name her butt oh
no uh see see uh down third row first
one on the left
with the man her her
daddy looks like like a skinny is this
our original dude yes okay he sucks too
he sucks he's the one
he's a piece of [ __ ] really hold up go
up go up oh i know what's going on there
this girl i know what's going on this
girl piece of [ __ ] real [ __ ] they get
into the house i told my girl before
anything happened i went i guarantee you
she [ __ ] this black guy my girl goes no
i go i can just smell the vibes of this
one okay
she gets into that [ __ ] thing and she
goes oh they hook up on this oh it's
like black.com she
here's the thing bee lines towards this
black dude who's handsome yeah but you
can tell it's going down well she is
really no here's my philosophy on this
that guy is really sweet and he's giving
her an ultimatum i want to either get
married or not she doesn't want her
she's not into them
guy's like he's really sensitive and
he's very sweet he's got beautiful eyes
he's a handsome dude
say they want that's what women yeah
they want here's the thing
uh
when men are that sensitive and they're
that like women aren't a family he's
real handsome he's overwhelming guys
women are gonna lose the church because
what happens is he's not a beast they
meet then they meet they meet a straight
cat
a straight large who's this black dude
josh they they meet
black panther uh-huh they meet a black
panther where's he at now you got a
domesticated you got a domestic poodle
at home oh she's cute cute cute
then you meet a black panther thing
uh-huh then you meet and all that
no she's pretty though she's great
i like her a lot
now here's the thing here's what i'm
saying okay what about the black people
she goes she said she's a beast too she
just that's tot
her man's a tall that's him that's taj
right there
that's who the white girl went for dude
everybody goes for him
he's the guy no he didn't go for her
though
don't tell me sorry
i want to know what's up with a tattooed
girl
long face
[Laughter]
but either way this guy's dave zane so
this guy jose's built like a brick [ __ ]
house he looks like he's all dude
he's all right goodbye he's got a good
ball he's also a nightclub promoter
oh good yeah he's you know what he is
he's a fuckboy he's a fuckboy no one's
who wants to marry and they just want to
[ __ ] him that's right i think he played
look at that picture with the hat didn't
you play basketball you know what that's
probably a good guess brian no he's got
a basketball tattoo and i think he's
about to i mean probably there's so many
people that i played
you know like that he was he was like
oh he's a handsome dude he's a dude he's
a bit of a [ __ ] boy though yeah he's a
[ __ ] he's a dude the point is though
if your girl's hanging with him and
they're just casually talking and you've
been and you've been just kind of like
you're a regular guy yeah
oh he's he's the small white guy who's
handsome but he's a [ __ ]
wait so the the white girls do smaller
than that yeah a small guy handsome but
he's just like too clingy wants to have
get made half kids
[ __ ] big
big
and they have to move in with each other
and lit and so they didn't say bad oh
like three after three or four days
maybe hooking up i i mean i'm only in
episode four but
that white girl yeah she all other man
she's on that black dude
well i could see that immediately
i was like dude you're gonna lose this
girl you you are
it's all good but she's not into you she
wasn't i said the minute i said i go
she's not into him uh-huh she also sucks
she's not very attractive but she's
something she's an [ __ ] i don't think
so no no [ __ ] that girl
he's a better person than she is
probably yeah this girl yeah she sucks
she's she's or
bubba or she's just not happy with it
they're just with the wrong people
yeah so she probably doesn't suck just
because she's not happy with that dude
no she sucks the show's doing them a
solid though the show to get to because
he's gonna watch back on this like oh my
god she's
right now oh okay i don't think yeah
most reality shows won't
post social media so they got to pretend
they're still together
do we little do we know but if you've
seen enough first 48 she's getting piped
down right now
and it's not by the short king you feel
me
you feel that me piped down oh he's a
shorter dude yeah god i remember i never
forgot i was with jimmy burke in new
york city and there was like there were
cops outside and the guy standing there
and uh
the cops are there and uh i see the
other the lieutenant comes up he goes
what happened he goes yeah he's trying
to climb into his uh girlfriend's
[ __ ] window and he goes what happened
what was that and he goes i guess the
girl's with a guy up there right now and
he's freaking out
and uh the lieutenant looks over and
goes
looks at the kid and the kid is [ __ ]
like just [ __ ] he's like so
he's raging
he goes girl's up there with another guy
and he goes yeah you guys
try climbing up there he goes yeah he
goes you know you can't do that right
and he goes no but he's she's up there
you know with this other guy and he goes
like this you know the cop said he goes
she did your solids now i guess
they had to wait there while the guy
walked away because you can't come back
here okay jesus christ it's so hard i
felt like going over there and giving
the guy a hug yeah that's life brother
he tried to climb up the [ __ ]
shirt
for me if a girl
[ __ ] if for me when a girl did that if
a girl just i remember a girl
she thought she hung up
i was dating we were dating yeah dating
you thought she hung up the phone and
she i just
i just hear her go i just hear that in
the background where am i that's so
funny
do you see my shoes where am i shooting
a grown voice you see my shoes
on my shoes you're like i swear to voice
just the deepest very white voice
sounded like he was a dragon you see my
shoes look at my shoes hey [ __ ] see my
shoes yeah and she goes i think they're
under the bed and i just went i was like
you just hear this movement
and then i was just like oh there it is
there we go and then you know she called
me and i about um like later on that
afternoon like hey no you didn't she
called you told me and all i said was
like oh i said um
did he get his shoes
and she goes ah [ __ ] brian i'm sorry
that's my old boyfriend
i don't know i didn't know where we were
at and i was like i get it i'm still
friends with her but it was like oh but
i'm not gonna hold that against you if
you don't like me
or whatever i ain't that's that's what
it is so when you're you gotta you kind
of gotta experience that
i just accept it i mean if you don't
like me you don't like me i i don't i'm
not gonna try to control your behavior
yeah ever no you're never gonna control
you have to control something you're
that way too yeah i don't give a [ __ ] no
you're not gonna control
find out dude
wait girlfriend for a long time
he's got a girlfriend okay it's a
romantic one when i was in denver she
comes to see him she comes to him when i
first moved to l.a she made the mistake
of having some stuff on her computer
that was just it just kind of popped up
and i didn't i've never had i've never
owned a computer i just i don't yeah i
don't want even back then before social
media i didn't want a reason to just be
online she sent her a computer so i was
like can i borrow your computer she's
like yeah not up but she had a long
flight from miami so i'm like all right
cool and then some of the email pops was
like bling i'm like
i said like xxx video and i'm like i
better check that out
gotta check that out i figured it was
like spam or something check it
a out brazilian man doing some freaky
[ __ ] with my girl yeah oh no freaky [ __ ]
with your girlfriend oh yeah brandon
just texted me because ah rough weekend
i was like oh well i guess it's over but
even with what you just ended it after
that obviously it was we still hung out
that wheel and she went back and never
talked to him but um it was what it was
she woke up i think she was like so
ambitious i'm so sorry and she was like
we're also not together i recently knew
in miami i was like i get it it's fine
oh okay a big brazilian dick i get it
congratulations yeah i hope you had fun
yeah kimberly guys filmed it like yeah
who the [ __ ] does that
turns you on a little bit but makes you
feel bad at the same time yeah i was
like well leave and never come back but
also send me that video hey i don't
understand why people film their [ __ ]
um weird
if you look good i guess you know i'd
just be too critical i'd be like the
[ __ ] you know you'd be like you'd be
looking you'd like
the lighting
my oval face
um
yeah there's been some tough but when
you're young you don't have perspective
when you're young and you're when you're
young and you're in love dude
you weren't in love were you i mean we
were together when i was in yeah in
denver no it's a betrayal it's a weird
you feel
you can't help it to feel [ __ ] if you
want to build a life with somebody and
you're going to get married to them or
you are married you start to feel that
energy and that's something yeah
[Applause]
try to pin your ears behind pin your
ankles behind your ears and lick your
bung holes that weird got a lot of weird
stuff that goes on weird holy [ __ ]
you're good
very nice upstanding career ladies and
gentlemen
their own careers i got thrown into the
deep end of l.a some girls would be like
look you're a big man and i need i need
measuring tape and chalk to find out
where i am i i want every inch you and
when i say every inch i mean let's start
with the old brown eye
mud whistle i hope the old blood was
much better yep
and he's like
you're playing with fire
hey listen you're a big guy you get on
all fours like a cow dude
playing
yeah
do you play uh pro football ufc 250 five
pounds all fours
i'm five two i'm five two very small
woman do me a favor let me grab those
big old ankles and i'm gonna push them
right over your head uh-huh
you find a happy spot on the wall to
look at and i'm gonna go to town a lot
of experience wild child over here yeah
it was fun
a lot of lots
a lot of good times
you have good days like those china
you're 45.
i would never allow that
hey let's take a little break let's take
a break let's take a break cause dude
i'm sick of paying so much money for my
prescriptions i wish there was a service
where i could save money and know
exactly how much i'm going to pay for my
prescription look how about good can i
save up to 80 yes good rx can it
instantly compares prescription prices
at pharmacies in your neighborhood and
it will find you discounts that could
save you up to eighty percent this is
nuts dude it's already free it's free
it's easy to use works whether you
have insurance or you don't even if you
have insurance go to our ex may actually
beat your co-pay perhaps about that you
can check what's up man online what are
you listening to listen dude they work
at over 70 000 pharmacies nationwide
like cvs kroger walgreens rite aid bonds
walmart so much more then take the money
you save with goodrx put it towards
filling your tank your shopping cart or
anything else that you got out there
that's really expensive so for simple
smart savings on prescriptions check
goodrx go to goodrx.com fighter that's
goodrx.com goodrx.com fighter good rx is
not insurance but can be used in place
of insurance medicare and uh medicaid in
2021 goodrx users saved 81 percent on
retail prescription pipe prices that's
crazy
goodrx.com hey b you know me man i'm a
sneaker head and some of my sneakers are
white and one thing about me like my
cars i wear them dude i push my shoes to
the limit push them i have these off
scuffed up dude i got these off-white
blazers they're all white they're my
favorite shoe the bottom turning yellow
because i wear them so much so i went
what can i do and then rejuvenator came
along dude and they look brand spanking
new how's that work dude over 2 million
satisfied customers with a 4.5 star
average review they have a patented
signature kit it's the most effective
shoe care product on the market and i
swear by it man i got cleaning
like a variety of cleaning projects a
mess yes man wow if you love shoes you
will need this right now reshuvenator
got you covered visit their youtube
channel to see them put their products
to the test on their latest sneakers at
youtube.com
revshuvenator so it's r-e-s-h-o-e
so rishu
and
the number eight are yup reshuvenator
yes yes for limit time reshuvenator is
offering the listeners and viewers of
fighting kid an opportunity to save 15
of the most effective shoe care line all
you need to do is visit reshuvenator.com
fighter you will save right at checkout
15 off rejuvenator.com fighter
we have a friend who got on all fours
and a girl that he didn't know jerked
him off uh he got on all fours
he was on all fours like a cow and she
milked him like a [ __ ] just like a
cow she went i'm going to church
and she had a head like a rottweiler
she had a head like a rottweiler i never
forget that i will never forget the
biggest head i've ever seen she had a
head like chun li from blood sweat well
she has yes well hold on
i'm gonna be i'm not trying to even be
funny
she had chin's head
thinking
she's five one yeah but with a skinny
neck you know the fish in when they
pollute a lake and the fish yeah their
bodies become skeletal and their heads
are huge because of the chemicals yeah
it's just the head that's what she
looked like and
she he kind of went on a date with her
and he said and she melted them and said
she put me on all fours and yanked mine
and that was it yeah because she didn't
want to have something about the sex it
was an issue i don't understand why she
wanted to get all four he was trying to
do something and she goes just just here
and she kind of she didn't speak english
very well and she goes here get on here
get here and he's like what the [ __ ] is
going on and she just went shankar shank
exactly
a few friends what a way to get a hand
your friends might have walked in too i
was getting milked like there there are
people who might have by
there's accident things you can't unsee
and i'll never be the same but sometimes
oh no sometimes things happen
so yeah y'all different breed dog
well i want to get you naked i want you
get i'll get you moving around in the
corner over there and i want to see
what's going on i want to get hands on
you too no you don't want to get hands
don't touch me listen to me as a friend
you want to melt them get hands on you
want to know
what's going to happen but you you hey
bill could be though
i want to see what you're working with
you're welcome to leave me
why i don't understand i don't
understand their culture i want to take
it that's not my culture you don't ever
scale that brian melchio and he ain't
touching me dude malcolm you listen to
me hey
malcolm yay man
hey
yeah let's go i'm driving downstairs
coming in driving down sunset just pull
over this group of galio milk man
do i get beat up
or do they move fellas jump in milk man
milk man
a lot of guys with milk yeah they'd be
very happy
chappelle no farmer brother once wants
to get his hands on you no
get you can't touch me
let me get that two percent out though
there you go
don't y'all [ __ ] nasty this is jen's
birthday man like your own [ __ ]
speaking of cheering let brian milk
not that cinnamon milk i don't think
brian wants to that's cinnamon milk yeah
birthday i'm a gay man
hell i'll massage the [ __ ] out of you
till my hands won't you once you melt
the marinara out of [ __ ] meatballs
milk the marinara get that ricotta
cheese out of this [ __ ] stromboli
over here
first we're gonna first we're gonna
shave you and we're going to call you a
twink we're going to tattoo twitter you
do look hairy yeah you're a hairy guy
huh you're a hairy guy not really really
your face begs the dick
you have a [ __ ] beard like it you're
from dagestan
it's going up there this beard
yeah you're a hairy guy yeah let me
steal his forearms
you're [ __ ] hairy
really i can see it from here yeah there
you go it's just normal hair yeah yes
no
he's got a cute little ass probably hey
y'all are [ __ ] yo hey why are we
doing this because it's it's gay
wednesday dude gay wednesday night we
always get gangsha's birthday what's up
tradition it's once a year tradition
dude what's here
let's uh let's go ahead and mash those
cupcakes all over my torso
they do look nice though these two look
nice
good so once again for the i don't know
how many episodes of of this podcast
we've done but seven we talk about dicks
every single day we've never had a 700
yeah or not
698 have been about
yeah we've never noticed yet we're still
here
789 today mm-hmm i'll tell you who i'm
true yep seven seven eighty nine seven
eight that's just the way we're gonna do
first that's just the ones that we're
over a thousand if you include yeah the
other ones wow
by the way i saw um the old fire in the
kid email
there's a bunch of stuff like old videos
of you guys
like doing fox days like behind the
scenes stuff so if you guys want to use
that material that's great i'd love to
see it yeah
there's a bunch though
dude i'm gonna be milking people in
arizona this weekend phoenix arizona
come get milked thursday friday
saturdays
hey
this week
can i finish milking my picture
let me melt this thing man
this thursday friday saturday i'm going
to stand up live melkin milk okay there
you go if you want to get milked
brandon will be there uh tampa tampa i'm
there tampa florida improv april 15 16.
port charlotte florida i come right back
to florida i don't [ __ ] around
comic theater april 21 22-23 las vegas
nevada wise guys comedy club april 28th
and 30th and then we got the stress
factory may 5 7. oh yeah and the big
milk happens uh april 23rd paramount
theater austin texas big ass theater so
we melt in april 29th your special day
april 28th april 28th
i [ __ ] it up
i'll be in austin at paramount theater
one show one night only with the thick
boy crew moon tower comedy festival
paramount we're milking each other april
23rd
someone get milked live on stage
on all fours
hey y'all hey y'all got to tell me who
it is after this episode sure
all right oh yeah you can only get
milked on all fours man you do it on two
feet you're you're a savage man
has to be all fours what do you got chin
good transition good transition thank
you sir these are going to be oh this is
kind of sad yeah um um godfrey passed
away from a long-term illness he had um
i don't know exactly what the illness
was but it had to do with his
cardiovascular system yeah it's his
heart that kind of thing is where your
heart beats really really fast for no
reason yeah it causes your uh heartbeat
to be irregular oh yeah two young
children i worked with i worked with him
twice on what on on uh
on um
[ __ ] csi
i believe i can't remember we had so
much fun jeff ross was on in the episode
but he was he's a beast he's to me the
funniest in some ways one of the
funniest people i've ever met just off
the cuff yeah you could not get anybody
fun his he was so witty and funny all
the time yep what a career
oh he had a big time career big time
just a great person man hilarious yeah
he was great and probably a child
he was great on there dude
yeah he was amazing man what a career
though good for him yeah terrible that
he passed away though yeah young too 67
pretty young man yes young [ __ ] yeah
what else you got right this is another
really sad one i promise i'll do some
fun ones after this oh they cop the guy
though yes they caught the man who was
responsible for the new york subway
shooting okay people are saying that
they were on the subway car and suddenly
someone threw a like some sort of smoke
grenade right yeah where black smoke
started to
eat up at every single inch of that
subway car and people couldn't see then
they started hearing gunshots go off
there were ten shots
and they believed that the gun stopped
because it got jammed when the subway
finally got to its destination and
opened up this its doors people started
rushing out 13 people were injured no
one died
he was five five
and i told my brother when it came out
and i was like i go hold on thirteen are
shot
and jay goes yeah and i go uh but nobody
died against no i go he was all like leg
and lower body shots you go oh
short as [ __ ] that was a short king dude
that's what happened there a man with a
nipple apparently more people like
someone would have died or more people
being shot if his gun didn't jam was he
shooting at their legs
this was the guy
yeah he's uh but he was on youtube which
is crazy they allow his footage on there
he's on youtube talking about racist
[ __ ] like you know
and he was talking about the homeless
situation he was going after the mayor
saying you know you've caused this and
you know i need to just start shooting
people and then what well he's he's
clearly lost his mind yeah well if he's
five five that guy on the right is
four foot ten
yeah i don't know
and they found him because he had
dropped a set of keys to a u-haul van
that was
uh i guess signed under his name so they
found the keys called the u-haul station
and they said oh it's actually
registered to this guy he's renting it
out right now yeah that's how they found
he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah and then the
blame it on mental illness and whatever
and guns you know no he's just a piece
of [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
all right yeah i was in brooklyn too
dude
yeah yep that's nuts man horrible
horrible
but thank god he's a such a [ __ ] up he
didn't kill anybody you couldn't even
get that right you [ __ ] loser i know
you even failed at that everybody
survived you [ __ ] [ __ ]
look at this girl so a animal
rights activist attempted to glue
herself super glue herself to the court
at the clippers timberwolves game
because the person who owns a large
chunk of the timberwolves also has a
factory
farm that has a bunch of chickens and
[ __ ] and she really wanted to show them
but she really thinks she could blow her
hands forever chickens anymore so i'm
gonna super glue myself but the glue
didn't have time to set so you just see
like it's a hot section so you see the
white hand print on the uh floors of the
basketball court afterwards they were
able to just wipe that [ __ ] what did
they say well she puts her hands down
they're not gonna let her sit there for
a minute till it's set yeah so this went
okay here this we're gonna take your
hands now so this is another view of her
trying to glue herself yeah she seems
like a smart lady
and that is the super glued hand wow and
she's doing this for animal rights yeah
for animal rights and it worked
all those animals were saved no no
chickens i [ __ ] hate chicken
yeah i'm going to eat chicken it's now
i'm going to eat chicken i don't want it
yeah i'm eating more yeah i nominate
more chicken because now all right
i'll take the chicken do you have any
baby chicks there's other way to protest
than that well it's a stupid technique
yeah
this is really the cause this guy is 14
years old and a twitch streamer who
streams call of duty every single time
he gets a kill he transforms his room
into an edm show so this is a club going
viral i bet he's crushing on twitch too
doing this oh yeah probably
i don't know that twitch world but it's
big that's you
[Music]
oh wow every time you get killed every
time you get killed it says pulse
147. that's actually pretty dope that is
crazy really i bet his parents are like
what in the [ __ ] right but if he's
making a bunch of money i mean i'd like
my kid do if he was balling myself if
that works can you not do it after
midnight though but the problem is my
son every time i try to get him to stop
he goes dad there are people making
millions on youtube playing games i'm
like i know that
you can't use that as a department
uh kane velasquez finally his first
statement since being arrested yeah i
saw this
now yeah i think he had a another uh
trial yesterday or another something you
saw him walking into the courthouse oh
and people everyone wants your friends
to support my family i will never be
able to thank you enough from the bottom
of our hearts and depths of our souls
we're forever grateful for your love
your selfless gestures and kind words
have given me strength in my darkest
times
uh this is the story is complex and
slowly unraveling as we speak this is
what's interesting is to the true
victims of the case may god give you
strength to come forward
uh though it is most difficult to re
relieve the pain that has happened to
you relive the pain that has happened to
you and speaking the truth just will be
served
and your own true healing will start
what happens what happens to him he's
going to go away for a little bit yeah a
little bit
a little bit i don't think like that
hopefully it goes to trial um
we need a trial because they're gonna be
more you know lenient if he goes to
trial that judge is a real kind i know
that you know what the judges the judge
is one of those people that uh would
refer to ufc fighting as [ __ ] fighting
she thinks he's like you know a
liability if they let him out on bail or
real yeah which he's not is he in jail
oh yeah yeah
he's still you serious yeah
well i don't know if he's posted he's
not you know
she can't like if she's a judge and he
goes and kills that guy then you know
that's i can see that if you chase
somebody down with a gun you're shooting
at him i i i don't think a judge had a
choice i i you know i don't know if it's
the judge i think the judge goes the
judge goes this guy
got in the car found the dude shot into
the car several times
uh try to run him off the road right and
yeah and it's also he doesn't have a
history of it no but if it's your kid no
history you don't know you can't control
someone yeah cause she gives him bail
and then he murders them he just keeps
thinking about like i didn't get that
yeah yeah it's a tough situation i think
i do sometime but not a ton
i hope not me too
he's gonna run that prison it's tough
though dude that's a real crime that's a
big there's there's no there are minimum
sentences 15 years minimum sentence
he's a good lawyer though they'll figure
it out i bet he does like around two
years plus with like good behavior and
all that stuff i think yeah his track
record he'll come out yeah
yeah he's already here yeah in that
community especially the mexican
community
also you don't got to worry about kane
velasquez in jail no no no no no i'm
saying that guy should not worry about
king velasquez there's other people that
want that [ __ ]
tough mexicans well when he if he ever
went to california state pen
that guy oh yeah that's a child molester
he's done things are not well that guy's
life's going to be terrible
his family's life is terrible too
they're all [ __ ] yeah and rightfully
so yeah
what else you got jen all right um have
you guys seen ali wong's special no
so in the special i'm not it's been out
for a little a little bit she keeps
talking about how she really really
wants to cheat on her husband it's like
a bit it's a funny bit and then you know
later on she says you know how she
wouldn't but apparently they're going to
divorce her and her husband after what
years of marriage
i don't know if it has no i know it's a
bit so but i mean the bit it's like
heavily into i really want to cheat on
him oh gosh yeah
but i was on a fight with her husband
he's so nice harvard graduate yeah he's
a beast oh [ __ ] she's she's a suit is he
an actor yeah no he's a
what you
for a know
or something joke about him selling like
uh her merch while she's on the road
because he went to harvard yeah he went
to harvard she paid off all his debt
damn
yeah
you know [ __ ] happens yeah
after eight years of marriage you said
eight years if two little kids it's just
right after special because i just saw
her special and when she was saying that
oh yeah
kitchen yeah it's good but it's i didn't
i never saw her stuff before no i
haven't seen it baby cobra is really
good baby cobra yeah that's her first
one that's what blew her up yeah
oh the one was the one she did when she
was pregnant yeah with the like cheetah
prince yeah cheetah prince
blue or
movies everything
so this sucks but philadelphia is going
to restore indoor mass mandates dude and
i got word from a buddy that works with
the
cdc today they're extending the mass
mandate in the airports another two
weeks it's going to i'm sorry more than
two weeks going to may 15th it's
supposed to end on may or april 18th
really it ends may 15th
because the new
variant is out
yeah and all the all the airline like
ceos are super against mass it doesn't
work that makes no sense think about
every time the pilot talks they go i
just have to say this you know i don't
want to do it sometimes sometimes you
get one of them soy boys on there like
hey make sure you have your mask on oh
no you're okay dude yeah
yeah yeah who knows how bad this variant
is but i'm guessing it's not going to be
no look at look at the hospitalization
it's not close
okay so we talked about elon musk
before you get into this i was talking
to my brother about he's a god i wish
you guys would [ __ ] research stuff
he's like the reason why he's not on the
board
is because if he's on the board they
limit how much stock can buy in the
company if he's on the board he can buy
all the stuff
he's like he's doing it because it gives
him more control and potentially buy
yeah
that's why i guess after 15 or 14.9
percent if you go above that then you
have to you know you can't be can't buy
it yeah yeah so he's like no i don't
know what i'm interesting that's why the
[ __ ] [ __ ] at uh twitter quitting
and freaking out
yeah so that's even better dustin off
the road take it over
isn't that funny take it over
uh so the guy tried to killed ronald
reagan yeah he apparently is a musician
now and he sold out some venue in uh i
think brooklyn wow what did you want to
hear your stuff yes did you try killing
reagan yeah yeah and this guy's doing
music let's hear it have you heard of
yeah i heard it
hello everybody hope you're doing great
listen if anyone knows of a record label
that would put out my music on vinyl we
sure don't
let me look nope
this little original
look at his eyes
everything i need
you got me thinking
that maybe i'll succeed
this is original too yeah i know this
original
original be cool
reagan yeah he's uh
just not all oh sorry
cat said this would be
like an awesome album cover which that
would be that's exactly what
it should be
wow
i can't believe he's out people were
just intrigued by stuff like this
yeah how much time did he do um
like all the years 30
was it 1980
81 was 34 years he did 34 years
or was it 81 or 82 when he wait he never
went to prison he spent 40 34 years at
saint something oh because he pled uh
insanity yeah oh
oh
all right
remember that preppy murder do you guys
remember that you're too young
to be murderer
murders robert yeah robert chambers
what happened to him what if he's still
alive
yeah you'd strangle people guilty to
manslaughter oh
[ __ ] manslaughter so what's he doing
failed to reach a verdict
i didn't realize i thought he went to
jail post conviction
to the drug charge you never do
sentences
yeah i don't remember that
i know the mendez brothers tick tock is
doing a big push to get them
out
yeah because what was uh i don't know
that story the two they murdered their
parents i know that but are they no no
absolutely he really the the main thing
that hinged on was that it was like you
you killed your parents a lot of people
but there was a lot of abuse right the
thing was that he he reloaded the gun
that was the one i think they shot the
mom in the back of the head it's like
you reloaded saw the mom crawling but
their parents treated them like the dad
the dad did yeah their their uh defense
was the dad didn't want him to leave the
house and they were going off to ucla
that and the the next morning the dad he
they thought according to their defense
he was gonna so was kill or be killed
okay they killed them
damn
damn
but they're saying if that trial went on
today through like you know mental
illness and they probably would have
they would have gotten off got off
really yeah are they they're doing life
oh yeah was dad truly abusive yeah he's
bad yeah he's bad
but they they recently saw each other
they had they hadn't seen each other in
like years in different prisons yeah
the one brother got married in prison
and
really but the what's interesting too so
they killed their parents and then they
followed the money and you know because
they got a bunch of money their parents
bank accounts they're like buying poor
shows and all this crazy [ __ ] damn there
they are damn you got the ones though
jesus
one of them had is handling prison
pretty well
interesting great show they're in
california jail i guess two
jails but in california now no they were
brought together in 2018.
oh now they're in the same way what year
was that man 89 was it
that that
trial was in 1990
no uh 1996 bubble wasn't it
89 89
yeah wow
apprehended in 1990 yeah there you go
damn
so so you said the thing was is that the
mom was crawling and they he reloaded
and shot again how old were they at the
time they were just teenagers just
graduating right 17-18 yeah
[ __ ] crazy
yeah we can't have that
wow
amazing
the documentary is great though oh it is
honor thy mother and father
21 21 and 18.
yeah that's old enough to know better
oh yeah you can't be killing your
parents also also 21 and 18 year old
boys or not men
are not that afraid of their parents
i mean you're not in danger that's my
thing the one that's like fight back
dude yeah just finally accused sexual uh
molestation
he said the dead no one's found any
evidence
nothing of it so we don't know if it's
actual truth or what's going on here i
think you're just people you beat the
[ __ ] out of your dad but killing him i
don't know
i don't know
what don't you guys you shouldn't kill
you
no that's right
um last one is it's not that new but
it's just dwayne johnson has i think
four different wax figures in four
different cities
and they actually look pretty good this
one's like the worst one though
that one looks good but yeah but the
other ones are way better so this is new
york i don't have a problem with that
this one looks really good they all look
like the eyes look a little like jason
statham the eye's a little different
here but that is the rock but watch this
one orlando
this one's
[ __ ] crazy
and that's in las vegas and then this
one here in hollywood i mean they all
look exactly like that and them wax
figures tripped me the [ __ ] out they're
getting a lot better now dude they
should be like
some of them were off yeah party b one i
think was a little rough
yeah i mean that looks like a man yeah
congratulations dude
four
you got four
do you want one of yourself no
i don't
but that's pretty much it
it's pretty wild
yeah i'll have the wax
those wax figures in uh
at the long beach lab factory creep me
out
are those wax figures just whatever the
hell those things are
that's it dude that's it all right kids
i'm off to phoenix tomorrow that's this
thursday friday saturday phoenix arizona
stand up live milk me and then uh april
20th
shauban friends one shove one shove one
show only one
hollywood improv with the monsters
hollywood improv that is 420 but i don't
smoke you can
texas
at the paramount theater one show one
night only the moon tower economy
festival got moved to the paramount
theater big venue for your boys so come
on out austin texas april 23rd one show
only may 5th through the 7th is
charlotte north carolina special drops
on thick boy youtube april 28th the
gringo poppy
tickets at f-a-t-k-z.com
or thinkboy.com right
oh i'll be in tampa florida this weekend
april 15 16 port charlotte florida
hassani comedy theater april 21 22-23
las vegas nevada wise guys comedy club
april 28th to the 30th and new brunswick
new jersey stress factory may 5 through
the 7th and here's a really good thing
to say
my special
is taping
may 19th at the brea improv tickets are
already on sale i will provide a link
and then may 6th and 7th i'll be in san
diego at mike drop comedy club may 12th
i'll be doing a one night or stand up
live and then uh in the summer june 24th
and 25th i'll be going to meatballs town
east providence rhode island to do uh
comedy connection
all right kids love ya that's it phoenix
see you this week